indeed one of the best players on the
planet wesley so wesley it's hard to win
a game at the u.s championship as you
have said and this one was insane he
left a knight sitting on f4
in the position what were your thoughts
in this crazy
bit of chaos that you faced in this game
yeah i thought i just missed a very good
chance to win today and probably the
tournament
so that's nice where where do you see
yourself having missed a chance yeah i
think that's several points of the game
in the opening i thought bishop d6 was
an inaccurate so it was much better but
also
um
yeah like here knight h4 g4 no yeah dear
i thought just knight d2
and uh
knight the f1 is much better for if i
say play knight d2 bishop e6
knight the f1 and then probably because
long knight g3 and i just think it's a
very difficult position for black could
be wrong but
i thought i have a very good chance here
because
if pawns are weak can't play h5 eyes
bishops
i mean
yeah i think this is very good for white
uh but the computer could prove me wrong
but also like uh here united phone was
unnecessary because after knight h5 g3
knight f4
uh i totally underestimated this piece
sacrifice
and then it's not clear what's happening
but um
yeah so so i believe knight f1
192791 was a very good chance
for an advantage uh also
later here probably
made mistakes maybe black could have
played better
but this provision very complicated i
think
g3 was a mistake
so also i think after p1 queen f6 was a
mistake
so here my second chance was
knight d2 rk894 on on 92 king b8 i guess
he missed something
so i think my second chance was knight
b6 and queen e4 and white is
consolidating it's a very good chance
but yeah 96 win if and then queen e4
um
it's probably just
technically winning for white i mean i
think white's consolidating black only
has two pawns
i could be wrong of course but yeah this
was
just winning but also like after king b8
94 queen f5 bishop e3 rookie 8 knight d6
rp6 i think bishop a7 king is seven
i thought queen d4 also i should play
queen d4 i was thinking for it for a
long time but
just decide to force the draw queen
before b6 queen a4 king b7 queen e8
so i was analyzing this queen d5 king
feet two
queen d2 king b3
25
sequin d2 on the move sorry
king b3 25 54
so you go give a check again c4
queen d3 king before
queen d2 king a3
and queen a5 queen a4
liking a3 this line seems all square
five playing four and i think my opinion
white is just
very close to winning at least very good
practical try so yeah mystery chances
today i think if i won today with a very
good chance to win the tournament but
that's just
i hear you say that's chess but it seems
like you're disappointed
yeah i mean the three three good chances
also i mean daniel's a very good player
very tricky player
but uh at the same time uh
yeah i had very good chances just blew
it
you got two more rounds to go uh two
players that you are theoretically on
paper supposed to be better against your
thoughts about that these last two
two games yeah i think um this
championship paper doesn't mean anything
i think everything
doesn't uh it's not such a big deal it's
all about form and
about consistency and
also uh
uh the way you
you treat the tournament psychologically
and uh uh
your oh it's like yeah
your your flow i forgot the word but
like um your flow and the torment needs
to be very consistent
all right i've never i've rarely seen
you so disappointed in fact
uh
the response seems a bit extra i'm
surprised by it
yeah i mean
today was a very good chance i think
all right well we'll let you go thank
you so much for joining us wesley just
to lighten up the mood a little bit yeah
don't forget to uh give the piece back
to the arbiters
i think you have a piece oh no i took it
from here
[Laughter]
okay
yeah
wesley don't kick yourself too hard just
a second just a second
i haven't kicked myself yet yeah well in
the variation that you gave at west uh
there's beer only of course queen check
no no no no i fell for it too i did the
same thing as you did queen takes e8 i
have overlooked
in this variation that you gave i also
fell for checkmate i missed c5 check
oh no this isn't the variation no this
is not the very skin day five yeah hold
on
no guys created
that's why i should play queen before oh
that's why you needed to play queen d4
and then play bc yeah okay kick yourself
hard
take myself very hard
yeah but i think uh as much as they have
been such a horrible game i've suffered
much worse so i'll survive
yeah yeah also the difference is that if
we can b6 queen d4 doesn't work anymore
because of c5 and so black is just
holding on
now now wesley
the situation at the top it's crowded at
the top there are a lot of people
gunning for the national championship
title
of this current situation who do you
reckon is
how it were doing the best ray is going
down
against uh
fishing
against uh
lanier's gonna win the game this is
i have it on my board
um
take a look yeah i don't know what's
happening is it over
it's about to be it looks like a
material advantage and attack for making
it back yes
precisely yeah king of six and then some
knight e8 knight e8 check looks like a
good way a 98 or sign yes oh is it
resign rookie 8
rookie 8 bishop e8 yeah it should be
refined right and rook f7 chapter
exchange
is
is it's it's over right so lanier might
be
also with you at plus two thank you yeah
no i'm always have a huge respect as i
said in my previous interview linear is
a very strong player uh if
he's he can play a 2800 level he's got
very good openings extremely powerful
opening preparation and he's very
consistent i think
the thing field copy performance 2800 i
won't be surprised if he wins this
tournament i i i thought
i thought he had very good chances to
win after round three
wesley uh get your mindset you've got
two more games they are the championship
rounds coming up
[Laughter]
we'll we'll be looking closely at your
games i think yeah
okay is that